was für ein wunderschöner
sonnenuntergang gehe ich mal zurück
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer endlich mal
wieder neuen mut vorstellung und zwar
ist es eine mod die ich habe ja schon
bei twitter und bei facebook gepostet
eine mod die mir besonders gut gefällt
beziehungsweise die mal etwas so ein
bisschen was neues mit reinbringen also
das ist jetzt keinem ort wo man sich so
denkt oder wurden zehn milliarden items
hinzugefügt und diese und das und bla
bla bla und so viele neue monster
sondern einfach mal was schön ist was
man mal selbst ausprobieren kann und
gucken kann ob es einem gefällt und was
eventuell auch eine idee für die zukunft
wer also jetzt wahrscheinlich schon im
titel gesehen bzw
irgendwie form intro oder so was also
ein pre intro es ist die motto cubes
motto cubes englisch auf deutsch
übersetzt heißt keine würfel also
einfach eine minecraft welt die komplett
warte ich bin ja irgendwo denn ich bin
einfach mitten im wasser gespart und
denkt migration wo bin ich also das hat
die auch selten dass ich irgendwie
wasser gestanden
es ist eine welt ihr seht ich will euch
zeigen hier ihr seht es
wir haben hier keine wir haben keinen
die unterwasser natürlich schon unter
wasser funktioniert ganz nicht wir haben
keine blöcke wir können hier die ganze
zeit so rüber laufen als wäre das
einfach eben also das sieht in der
animation orkane höhle
das sieht in der animation noch ein
bisschen länger aus das kann man nicht
besser einstellt ich kann ihnen die
einstellung in grafik engine ich hab das
ja alles auch schön wenn ich das auch
schnell hat ist das so wenn ich das
allerdings auf schön habe ist das auch
so also das macht keinen großen
unterschied
ich kann allerdings hier einfach
hochlaufen et cetera wenn ich allerdings
sprinte ist das wird das direkte blog so
kann ich da natürlich super sprit aber
wenn ich beim sprint wird das geblockt
da das ganze natürlich immer noch blöcke
sind eigentlich die unterschiede sind
und das ist auch so ein bisschen doof
dass man mich zum beispiel in block
runter gehe oder hier so halb draufstehe
stehe ich hier halt auf den blöcken das
ist also ein bisschen kaka dann stehe
ich als in der luft die animation ist
noch nicht so gut aber ich finde von
hand idee an sich natürlich minecraft
ist ein spiel was von den blöcken lebt
also wir haben in minecraft nur blöcke
alles was wir setzen ist aus blöcken
aber ich finde vor allem wenn man
irgendwie so vom wasser kommt und man
sieht also das ist jetzt blöd weil ich
im strand haben
da sieht man das jetzt nicht so kalt da
sieht man schon viel besser aber auch
ein bisschen doof weil er immer noch
diese erstellen sind weil gerade bei
solchen bergen das sieht man zum
beispiel hier sind gerade diese
erstellen halt nicht mehr vorhanden
da sieht man hier sieht man das
wunderschön oder auch hier dass man
einfach wenn man hier so drauf zu
schwimmen das man einfach sonnenberg
sieht weil darstellt nicht immer
insgeheim wenn man diese ganzen scheiß
erdbürger hätten sie also dass man
irgendwie so oder so ähnlich läuft
einfach mal hoch also drückt nicht
sprinten ich laufe einfach diesen berg
hoch das ist ganz nah ich finde es
eigentlich ganz schön traurig ist
bisschen das gut das heißt traurig ist
eigentlich auch cool ja cool ich habe
eine tiefe bekommen
ich kann hier drauf bauen also dann
verändert sich das ganze das ist
allerdings schwer
also ihr seht dass ich drücke hier drauf
obwohl der block eigentlich drauf gehen
müsste er hielt aber nicht drauf das ist
ein bisschen komisch und jetzt kann ich
hier allerdings nur ein blog draufsetzen
wenn ich da irgendwie von obendrauf
drücken wenn ich von der seite darauf
zurückgekommen da hier in das wird halt
alles so als block gesehen und das ganze
bauen wird
da insgeheim um geheimnis seiner
insgeheim erschwert als wenn er noch so
ein blog darüber wer das heißt nämlich
darauf stelle stehe ich quasi in der
luft also ein paar fehler sie noch
vorhanden aber an sich ist die mod auf
jeden fall sehr sehr schwer zu machen
dass bauern widmen tisch erschwert hier
drauf unter wasser funktioniert ganzen
nicht das habt ihr schon am anfang
gesehen also wir sehen hier unter wasser
ist das ganze scheiß egal da ist es ganz
normal wenn man über wasser ist das
terrain ist sieht schon cool aus also
mit der grafik natürlich kaffee
entscheidungen bisschen scheiße aber es
ist mal was anderes hier zum beispiel
dieser sandberge e-mails kuhn s7
vielmehr auswiegen der bühne oder so
oder allgemeiner wüste wäre das immens
immens geil einfach ich finde es richtig
cool in der wüste mit diesen mit dieser
mod einfach das bauen ist wie gesagt
noch ein bisschen schwer
also ich krieg zum beispiel da drauf und
der blog wird dann beispielsweise hier
wenn wir das jemals in der blog wird
quasi einfach jeder teilweise ersetzt
also jetzt gerade mitsamt punkt recht
gar nicht da war es gerade das blog hat
wenig einfach ersetzt wird wenn wir da
drauf klicken
es ist ein bisschen komisch aber ich
finde da habe es auch gerade gesehen ich
finde allgemein von einer idee her ist
es auf jeden fall super und ich finde es
sieht geil aus weil man einfach so sieht
und dann so und sandberg und man kann
dann halt so hoch laufen und so und muss
nicht immer so blöd springen es ist eine
coole idee das muss man wirklich sagen
jetzt fragen sich natürlich der einige
was passiert wenn man das kaputt schlägt
wie ist dass es nicht gleich vier
kleinere glocke
wenn man das kaputt steht kann man so
kleine wege herstellen hier oben sieht
man das nicht sogar aber wenn ich zum
beispiel mal hierhin gehe wo flachland
ist ein bisschen kann man halt so kleine
wege dadurch erstellen das ganze hier so
ein bisschen kaputt schlagen dann
bekommt man das ganze halt auch in etwa
auf eine ebene ebene also das kann man
damit quasi provozieren
und wenn man da die blöcke draufsetzt
fällt einem das beinahe schon viel
einfacher okay hier passt sich das ganze
jetzt an diese scheiße dann aber hier
auf jeden fall kann man ein paar coole
sachen erstellen allerdings ist das
ganze hat noch ein bisschen erschwert
die mod ist noch im anfangsstadium ich
wollte euch nur noch mal vor schon mal
vorstellen
ich habe gesagt es wird jetzt keine
riesigen vorstellung wo ich mich zehn
milliarden jahre dafür vorbereitet habe
sondern einfach ich wollte euch mal
zeigen
das ist so etwas gibt weil ihr oft um
minecraft klone entwickelt werden wo
dann einfach gesagt wieder kommen hier
bei minecraft die es dort
hier sieht das besonders schön aus mit
der düne war das so genau
hier hoch geht das es so dass schöne
finde ich damit könnte man auch noch
super ebene schimek mal machen oder so
was also es gibt da wundervolle sache so
witzig ehrlich der wasserdoktor unter
kippe das haben ja gar nicht gemacht
aber ich wollte euch halt einfach mal
zeigen was passiert wenn wenn eine
mutter entwickelt wo minecraft einfach
keine blöcke sind
ihr seht viele fehler aber es ist auf
jeden fall eine coole sache und ich
finde die idee an sich eigentlich
megacool nur halt dass das ganze jetzt
hier so ein bisschen noch ein bisschen
buggy ist muss er selbst zugeben das
ganze fließt jetzt hier irgendwie so
crazy runter naja egal ich finde es auf
jeden fall immens cool wenn die zeit
habt und lust habt ist es in der 17.2
könnt ihr euch einfach fortschritte
laden doppelklicken auf install klicken
und dann einfach dieser mod in dem
ordner rain cii ist auch als auf der
nordseite erklärte ich euch und in der
beschreibung verlinkt habe es ist noch
ein bisschen komisch vor allem also in
höhlen hat nicht diese sachen aber
besonders hier findet zum beispiel
relativ cool also dass er einfach keine
blöcke sind die läuft durch und das ist
ganz cool eigentlich das liegt alles ein
bisschen schön aus und diese ehrt blöcke
sind seltener vorhanden was mich
besonders freut weil ich das immer eklig
fand aber sonst man kann jetzt so
einfach hoch laufen das ist eigentlich
richtig cool sieht halt viel wilder aus
ein bisschen minecraft das finde ich
eigentlich ganz cool
deswegen wollte ich euch die mod einfach
mal vorstellen wenn es euch gefallen hat
und eventuell mehr von solchen nicht
revolutionieren woods haben will sondern
fans die nichts hinzufügen sondern
einfach etwas verändern haben wollt dann
drückten daumen nach oben schreibt seine
kommentare will ich sagen
hier würde